كريستيانو رونالدو يرفض واعتزال اللاعب
الدولي محمد صلاح وانجاز والمغرب
تتابعونها على العربيه رياضه
[موسيقى]
الاخرى منتقده لهجوم المتابعين على محمد
صلاح باعتباره غير مبرر او مفهوم وانا
توقيته غير مناسب على الاطلاق
رواد السوشيال ميديا تفاعل ايضا مع تقارير
الصحفيه برتغاليه تؤكد ان كريستيانو
رونالدو لا يفكر ابدا في اعتزال اللاعب
الدولي وبحسب المنشور فان من السابعه
والثلاثين عاما مستمرا مع منتخب بلاده حتى
لو بقي فرناندو سانتوس اعلى راس القياده
الفنيه وانه سيكون مفيدا لمنتخب البرتغال
حتى كاس امم اوروبا
2024 التقارير واشارت ايضا بان رونالدو
يعتقد بانه لم يكن في افضل حالته في
مونديال قطر بسبب عدم لاعبيه بصوره منتظمه
في مانشستر يونايتد الانجليزيه وهو امر
اثر على مردوده الفني
والى من تميز بابتسامته البريئه الدائمه
في كاس العالم ياسين بونو حامي عرين
المنتخب المغربي هذه الابتسامه التي تعتني
محيره وتتحول الى ضحك هستري خلال ركلات
الترجيح لها مدلول خاص ومؤشر خفيف بحسب
تصريح الادلبي اسد الاطلس اوضح فيه ان هذه
الابتسامه ما هي الا محاوله لخوض لعبه
عقليه مع الخصم لاخراجه عن تركيزه
واستفزازه والتقليل منه وبالتالي يفقد
ثباته والتجاره وصبق للحارس المغربي ان
استخدم هذا التكتيك امام مهاجم روسيا دورت
من السابق في مباراه امام اشبيليه بدوري
ابطال اوروبا الموسم الماضي
في التصدي للرحله
الختام مع نيمار دا سيلفا فبعد فتره طويله
من مواجهه تها من وحضور جلسات في محاكم
عده تمت بريئه اللاعب البرتغالي البرازيلي
من تهمه الاحتلال والفساد في صفقه انتقاله
من سانتوس الى برشلونه في 2013 وشملت
البراءه ايضا والدين مار ونادي برشلونه
ورئيسيه السابقين بارتينيا الى جانبي نادي
سانتوس ورئيسه السابق والشركه التي اسسها
والد نيمار لاداره اعماله
[موسيقى]